this past week I was in Charlotte North
Carolina in the days following the fatal
police shooting a 43 year old father of
seven keith Lamont Scott I was on the
ground with protesters who took to the
streets nightly demanding justice for
Scott he was killed by police who were
originally at his housing complex to
serve a warrant to someone else Scott's
family said he was sitting in his car
reading a book LA Police said he had a
gun the community I met with was both
pained and outraged by yet another
tragic case of a person of color killed
by police in the u.s. here's why for a
lot of the folks I spoke to Scott's
death served as another reminder that
being black in America means you can't
guarantee your own safety this sadness
Garrett because that could have been me
or that could have been anybody getting
out of their car for whatever reason
that you would assume that you know
we have better you know better decisions
a bit of choices on how to handle a
situation like that for a number of the
women I spoke to seeing the cellphone
footage shot by Keith Lamont Scott's
wife just a few months after falando
cast Steele's fiancee live streamed his
death at the hands of the police
was particularly painful it hurts me
African American woman that every time I
kiss my working goodbye there's and
that's hurtful how am I supposed to
raise my future sons to try to tell them
that this isn't okay this is what we can
do to be safe when there's no way to say
how to be safe and that needs to be
address second how the police handled
the aftermath of the shooting only
furthered the mistrust of the community
it took them five days to release the
body in dashcam footage to the public
they eventually did no doubt in large
part due to the mounting pressure of
protesters but what they did actually
end up releasing was just some of the
footage not all and unfortunately this
may be the last police footage ever
released in North Carolina thanks to a
new law that goes into effect October
1st that basically says police no longer
have to make such videos a matter of
public record
then there's the footage itself which
really generates more questions than
answers
it shows Scott slowly backing away from
this car with his hands at his sides
before getting shot four times he wasn't
making any aggressive gestures and you
can't even tell if he's holding anything
even the police chief agreed on that
point the police also released photos of
a gun ankle holster and a marijuana
blunt all allegedly Scott's but North
Carolina is an open carry state and
since what is smoking marijuana and
aggressive behavior that warrants
getting shot by police all of this has
reignited the debate about excessive
force used by cops and the implicit bias
and fear that comes along with policing
black bodies yeah his wife there she was
there for safety she could easily talk
to him down
they didn't think of the got her
involved in chose not to they could have
taken other steps as a team to not have
it in is this just another case of
police bias and if so when will it end
[Music]